welcome to the heavyspoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Alison Borderlands season
two the first series ended in a big way
and in it we followed several characters
stuck in a city that was spelled with
deadly games and obstacles those that
one were given specific playing cards
that all helped hidden out things like
the game's difficulty and themes Spades
were physical games clubs were team ones
diamonds were an intelligence test and
hearts were an emotional one the number
represented the difficulty the
characters had to play these games in
order to collect these cards the
survivors we fall out eventually ended
up in a beach hotel where several of the
players collected all the cards because
they believe that attaining these would
send everyone home in the end they were
forced to play a literal Witch Hunt in
order to get the elusive ten of hearts
in the end it was revealed that the
victim a mocha was actually the witch
herself and that this was all an
elaborate ruse controlled by the game
makers before they could place her in
the fire of judgment naragi showed up
and they juked it out whilst the place
burned around them they eventually threw
her body into it and found footage about
her and Asahi who had revealed herself
as one of the dealers during the games
these are characters that organized the
games to extend their visas meaning that
they didn't have to constantly take on
challenges in order to stay alive now
turned out they'd found the game
Master's Lair which is where Harry soon
usagi ended up traveling too here they
met her with their allies Chi along with
queen air and discovered the game
Masters dead it was revealed that they'd
all been players as well and a woman
named Mira appeared and announced that
there would be new games for the base
cards in season 2 we learned that she's
the queen of hearts and we'll talk about
this more towards the end of the video
that should be fully caught up and for
the rest of the breakdown it's full
spoilers ahead for season two if you
enjoy the video please hit the thumbs up
button and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day by the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into Alison Borderlands season
2.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so for the first part of the video I
sort of want to go through a quick recap
of the season in the game so that it
adds more context to the end if you want
to skip ahead though I won't be mad and
I'll even tell you what's on the back of
your neck this Spade mate it's a spade
honest now I love the way this season
opens with us watching violence in a
game and how it's used for entertainment
which juxtaposes the Mayhem that we
could to in Borderland from here we pick
up immediately after the events of
season one and watches the survivors
from the beach return hunted by an
anti-tank rifle the series begins with a
bang and it plays out with them pretty
much becoming fish in a barrel who
watches the King of Spades Maneuvers
through the town with his blimp behind
him and these new boss level characters
become some of the main antagonists in
the series absolutely love the plot
devices of these and it adds an extra
Dimension to the game the King of Spades
is different to the other ones as it has
no designated area and its head shirabi
is something that we discover more about
in The Source material he was an
extremely skill old mercenary who
carried with him the belief that to live
is to suffer thus he sees these killings
as being acts of mercy and his strategy
tends to be to let people Gather in one
place in a large number so that they're
easier to dispatch now in his dying
breath we see a flash of him standing
over a man with his gun drawn the manga
tells the backstory of this in full and
this was his War buddy Apache they were
dispatched on a job Behind Enemy Lines
and it was revealed that this was pretty
much a suicide mission that had them as
sacrificial Lambs Apache was badly
wounded and though sharabi tried to pull
him out of there he begged for death
Apache knew it would give his friend a
better chance of surviving but he also
saw it as saving him from the pain he
would spend the rest of his life in his
very short life but still it would stop
him from that pain he said that he'd be
saving him by shooting him which again
extends to sharabi's outlook on life now
arisu suspects that each blimp has its
own game master and that defeating the
kings and queens is the key to going
home at after arriving at the King of
Clubs they're greeted by naragi who ends
up becoming the fifth player in the game
they pretty much play hide the sausage
against the King of Clubs and what we
learn are the citizens of the country
these are the vectors of the previous
cycle that ended up winning and shows to
stay in Borderland unlike the other
players they don't have visas and they
have permanent residency though they do
have to play in the games though they
could be written as two-dimensional
characters it's actually easy to become
attached to them and because of their
sportsmanship you're kind of root for
them too the King of Clubs kiyuma
emerges as a big character from this
initial game and having to edit around
this dude because of YouTube's
demonetization policy felt like its own
Borderlands challenge now in the end he
and his team lose and the original manga
actually adds some extra context to his
final thoughts it states that he lived
his life to the fullest and it doesn't
have any regrets in the source material
we learned that he arrived five months
before arisu and worked his way through
the games which got him to this position
well that's where we see Chi playing the
Jack of Hearts game at the ciao prison
oh I pronounce our I'm probably
butchering all the pronunciations to be
fair now it's basically like that bit in
the office but here they have to whittle
each other down to find out who the Jack
of Hearts is by saying which suit they
are due to it being shown on the back of
an explosive collar it starts off all
fun and games but over time the knives
come out with contestants lying to each
other so that they can come out on top
she doesn't have any allies in the game
unless he has to guess who's lying to
him and through the process of
elimination by the ant is given he
narrows it down to a 50 50 Choice he
goes with his gut and gets it right and
exposes that the true Jack was
communicating with another player
through all cafeteria snacks a exposed
he's taken out and we also discover more
about Borderland itself now Borderland
is basically this stay between life and
death in which players receive several
things either they die and continue unto
death or they live and get to remain
there or return to the world those that
are pulled into the city are picked
because they've had a near-death
experience that will talk about more in
just a bit thus they're pulled in and on
their Journeys they see what life really
means to them if they survive they can
go back and those that manage to return
don't remember anything from their time
I bet the manga shows that these
memories can be accessed under certain
conditions Amira does have some fun with
them and she basically does every single
time
that we had after the first season in
the Manga she lies several times about
what's going on and initially says that
it's virtual reality this is married in
the show with her explaining how
nanotechnology LED Humanity to control
the whole world and in one thousand
years in the future we exist on dopamine
which is why you should hit the thumbs
up button and the source material she
says that in this VR world the prize for
winning is to be able to stay longer and
design more games but where she reveals
that to [ __ ] lie much like the manga
she then says it's aliens and Androids
and just talk [ __ ] about how they're
actually in a therapy session it
perfectly recaptures the original work
and I'm sure fans will appreciate how
close this is now in the manga though
the therapy session isn't real it does
make ariesu realize that he's being
drugged therefore he kind of has it
spoiled about exactly what's going on
and the hospital reveal that comes at
the end by the end of the show though he
uses you saggy and what she means to him
to power him on through the games now in
reality all of the characters in
Borderland have been hit by mysterious
meteorite that descended on Tokyo chunks
of the asteroids struck people and these
are the fireworks that the characters
keep referring to now this destroyed the
city leaving them critically injured and
causing the Borderland experience the
wounds that they gained in the
experience all to reflect the ones they
have in real life and they all have this
feeling like they know each other though
they can't remember why there's lots of
timey why me wibbly wobbly stuff and the
entire time in Borderland is just a
minute in the real world those that were
closer to the blast ended Borderland
first and this is why some arrive before
the others and we see the borders of
Borderland in this city and witness
overgrown forests a never-ending
mountain range and also some elephants
now in the woods arisu mitsuguni who
survived the events of the first season
as well haunted by his past he's teamed
up with a cane who lost a leg during a
Dark Knight Rises challenge battling it
out with the King of Spades he becomes a
big threat for the season along with the
remaining face cards there's some big
games throughout the season and players
even taking acid baths which fills in a
lot of the people's lives in episode 6
we also see the reason why momoka
sacrificed herself and decided to become
the witch she wanted to show that people
were in selfish and this inspiration
ends up helping to save chi in the end
slowly the face card games are played
and this happens in a montage so cool
you'll be walking away from the
explosions with your backs turned to it
the raggy shows up to take out arizu and
Chi and after you Nagi shows up she does
the ultimate sacrifice in order to save
her life and though she survives and
they try to tend to his wounds this is
cut short when the King of Spades
arrives looking like black noir easily
the most threatening villain they've
faced in the series he ends up wounding
a cane and Anne before going
head-to-head with a goonie Queener is
stabbed with a Goonies seemingly being
killed as well and it felt like watching
your favorite DCU actors posting white
text on a black background thankfully
they weren't killed and no I knew what
was going to happen I was still like oh
no I can't believe they've done this now
they lure him to a Kill room and a
goonie arrives and blows him up leaving
him at that store which is when he ends
his life he sees a vision of him
standing over Apache which is murdered
in The Goonies seeing his own vision of
the past Elise just ariesaggy to face
off against Mira and this all plays out
in a game of croquet here we have the
constant head playing out with arisu
coming out the other side in order to
finish the game Harry suiters and
quitter forfeit the match unless the
game ends with him finally winning mire
is killed and the surviving players
either have to accept permanent
residency or they can just decline it of
course none of the characters want to
stay and you Sagi and arisu both Decline
and bring the conversation from the
first episode full circle now he has a
vision of his friends and Promises to
live his life to the fullest this is
reflected throughout both the series in
original work with him deciding to turn
his life around and go to college when
we look at how his Arc progresses in
that that doesn't happen in the show but
he decides that he won't let anything
hold him back anymore and gains a new
outlook on life man even steps have been
played with you saggy finally gaining
some game after smashing the game
queenette is reunited with her mother
and the pair end up sharing a heart to
heart I'm pretty sure that they added
her father for this scene too with him
being missing originally I think but let
me know below if I'm misremembering that
now we close out with it seeming like
the survivor's got a happy ending
however we start to zoom in on an
ominous Joker card I don't know if we're
going to be getting a season 3 but if we
do then they're probably gonna expand
more on this with it revealing what was
actually going on the entire time now
the manga wrapped up with the games
being beaten and when the Queen of
Hearts was defeated the Joker then
appeared it was revealed that he was the
ruler of the game and that he was
looking over everything in everyone now
we don't learn whether he's a God or
something else and in all honesty he
acts more like the ferryman from Greek
mythology it's said that he believed
there was too much random death caused
by the meteorite and thus he wanted to
give everyone a second chance to return
to the land of the living thus he set up
this limbo between life and death and
this carries a way for people to make it
back home it also gave them the
opportunity to remain in Borderlands so
that they didn't have to return to the
world if they had miserable lives now
the card's inclusion here could just be
in nod to the ending of the original
work as he doesn't appear in the show
like how he did in that whether it could
also hint at there being one more game
that they're all stuck in and the way
it's presented does make it seem more
Sinister The Joker Is of course a wild
card one that changes everything and the
Joker is also known as being a trickster
thus this could all just be a trick a
game within a game that robs them of
hope I think that's through they could
take in season three with their possibly
being a focus on them getting their
Memories Back and realizing everything's
not real this could end with the Joker
being revealed but again it's difficult
to predict this stuff as it differs from
the manga ending but that's basically a
Lowdown of what this means and whether
this is the last season or not you know
I think it does wrap things up nicely
now answer my thoughts in this series I
think this topped the first and
throughout I was constantly grabbed by
how tense the games were the series
really hit the ground running from
episode 1 and it felt like a constant
game of cat and mouse Alison Borderland
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your favorites
either and I was shocked at how
merciless they were with some of the
debts at points I was just getting
attached to these characters this was a
bloodbath but much like the first season
we also had some really great human
moments it could be so easy to turn this
just into mindless violence but it's
paced so well with each over-the-top
scene being made perfectly with a more
toned down human one every character
feels like they've grown and there's
several discussions between the people
who want to remain in Borderland and
ones that want to return home the game
is of course a metaphor for real life
with people scrambling over the top of
each other just to get slightly further
ahead than everyone else there they're
constantly knocked down and beaten but
they're awesome let's see the Simplicity
of the city as being more manageable due
to having more straightforward rules
however there's also the fact that
people are killing each other just to
add another day and there's genuine Hub
that they can make the world better it
really adds so much to the season and
this Mystery Box constantly kept me
coming back for more making it an easy
binge I think some people might be put
off by the pacing early on because those
first couple of games don't play out as
quickly as they did in the first season
however I think there's a lot more
complexity to them and the character
building that they do by dragging them
out actually adds so much more the
reveals in the color game were so good
and I love how the series also changed
the locations too we got far beyond the
usual City stuff we had last time and it
added so much more variety anyway really
enjoyed it and I hope you had fun with a
breakdown too in the end this was great
and I get a 9 out of 10. anyway that's
the video and obviously I'd love to your
thoughts on the series and what you
think will happen next time by running
competition right now giving away Dawn
of the Dead and Black Adam the 3
subscribers on the 15th of January and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop comment below with your thoughts on
the show if you want to be able to watch
we've got a video on screen right now
just for you and if you don't want to
watch it you know what have a have a
great Christmas and a great new year as
well if you're celebrated yeah all the
best for 2023 and I hope to see you on
the next video will you take care
yourself mate peace